- All right Jim.
- Yes.
Jim, So we were talking
last time as maybe a couple
of weeks ago, about how
traumatic your childhood was
with your dad,
and what you're doing with
animals now, Sometimes you eat.
- Yeah, i eat animals, I eat
dogs and cats, Catch him.
(Sighs)
- What, did the talk we have had a couple
of weeks ago help you at all?
- Yeah.
It helped me a lot.
Helped me deal with my problems.
I felt like I got an outlet.
- Yeah, You're welcome here anytime.
What, what do you see for your future?
do you have any hope for
things getting better or
improving or anything.
- I trying to take one day at a time,
and not count the days
before they get here.
- So do you have friends on the street
that you can trust and talk
to and things like that?
- I have associates,
yeah, but it's not the same.
- I know it's not.
it's kind of hard talking to
people, but it takes time.
It takes time talking to people.
- If I made it easy for
you, would you want to go
over to one of these many places that are
in the neighborhood to talk to somebody?
- I can to try, all I can do is try.
- Yeah, I think that might be,
might be therapeutic for you.
- Okay
Let me do that.
Do you have any family at all?
- No, not really, that I can go to no.
- Nobody you can,
this is your,
- This is my stopping ground.
- This is where you hung?
- Yeah.
You have no place to go for
holidays or anything like that?
- No.
- You're just here?
- Yeah.
- Have you ever had a girlfriends
or anything like that?
- No.
- Never?
- It's hard to have relationships.
people are different.
- Yeah, Well, I mean,
most of the people down
here playing around with drugs
and that makes it harder.
- I don't do any drugs at all
- Yeah. I know, but everyone else is.
(Laughs)
that makes it harder.
- I don't see How could you do drugs
and live in this type of environment?
I couldn't do it.
- Yeah, It's hard enough just being here.
- Yeah.
- But I think they go hand in hand.
- Sometime it's hard to get food
or water or somebody is not coming out
passing out food or something.
It's hard I would catch me a dog.
- Did you have any
remorse over doing that?
- No.
- No You're just feeding yourself,
and dealing with some anger maybe
right?
- Yes.
It's the only way I can eat some times,
I'm not gonna wonder in no
store and still nothing.
No, not gonna do that.
- Yeah.
So it gets kinda rough
and then you get grind me
I'll go look for one of them
animals, they going to slip,
they're going to come to you
quicker than the person will.
- If you, if you can talk to
a six year old version of Jim
when he was a small
child, what would you say
to him?
When he was going through all
that, all that stuff with his.
- Talk to someone, talk to
someone and get some help,
before it gets to worser,
it will be worse than what it is.
To where you're actually eating an animal,
when you actually eat animal, tastes good,
really tastes good.
put a little seasoning on it,
hey, Its like chicken.
(Laughs)
- I think at the risk of having
a million hateful comments
on YouTube, which tastes
better dog or a cat.
- Well, it both taste different.
It's different meat, It's different.
One tastes sweeter than the other.
- We'll leave it at that.
Did you have friends as a kid?
- I was a special ed so I really didn't.
I was always thrown out the class
or the class clown or
never We really tried to
get the attention on
my learning disability.
So it was kinda, I kinda,
kinda didn't really talk to people.
- Have you, have you ever had a friend?
- I had somebody to talk to him before,
and they left, they moved out of state.
So I don't really have no one.
- And you never did.
- No.
it gets kinda rough being to yourself,
but at the end of the day,
if I made it through the
day, it's a blessing.
- Do you feel like you're happy
or do you just go through life
Just surviving and depressed?
- I go through life,
surviving and depressed man,
It's it's rough sometimes man.
I'm telling you to get really
critical when you don't have.
- What's the, am sorry.
- Have anyone to get some information from
or to help you out emotionally.
- Yeah. Well, let me,
let me do something for
you after we're done here.
Maybe that might help.
- Yeah
- What, what was the
darkest period for you?
Was your childhood worse than it is now?
Or was there a period in the middle,
that was tough?
- My childhood was worse.
At least in society,
you can kind of like ignore, walk away
from people, or it gets,
sometimes it get complicated too.
Because someone would be
talking to you, and you
think they talking to you, but
they're not talking to you,
and you answer.
And then they asked you, what
are you talking to me for?
And I'd say, you was just talking to me.
So it gets kind of rough, man.
You gotta, you gotta be able to walk away,
and not feel the anxiety that,
you felt right at that moment.
- Yeah.
Did you, did you ever see a
therapist throughout your life?
- Yeah.
- And how did, how did that,
what was that experience like?
- It's like, it's like prying man,
people pry in your business
and I kind of don't
like people prying but.
- Do you feel like I'm prying,
Like the last talk like this one?
- No, I thought this
was really helpful, man.
I ain't eating no little
dog around cats this week.
I did the mission, so
it was pretty decent,
so I didn't have to do nothing crazy.
- Good, What'd you eat at the mission?
- I ate some beans, rice,
some grits and some eggs,
some hard-boiled eggs,
some fruit and salad.
- Sounds great.
- Yeah, it was pretty good.
- Do you have any dreams of anything like,
do you ever fantasize about
some other kind of life?
- Man.
- What do you, what do you envision?
- I was rich.
- What would you do if you were rich?
- I would just give people money,
cause that they wouldn't,
they don't know what it
is to, to have some money.
So I don't even know
what it is having money,
but I wouldn't be greedy
would spread my wealth.
I would like, not know how to get a job,
be social work and be able to.
How would you say a
negative society without
anyone's help kinda.
- Just be self-sufficient.
- Yes.
And being able to,
I wish I didn't have the childhood.
I can't change that, but I
can also change my future.
So, if I can try to work
on that some type of way
and then I love to get
a job, but you dealing
with people on a job
it's just kinda harder
than going to school,
because they nitpick.
They look for something for,
how would you say to,
get in your position?
And they will probably want the position
before you got there.
I don't, it's it's the battle
of who's going to get what.
- Yeah. Well, maybe there's a position.
You'd find that isn't,
you're not under somebody's
thumb all the time.
- I just don't want to be on nobody like,
if it just sweeping the floor,
I know what I'm supposed to do.
I don't have to get confused or
if I'm doing the wrong job.
- Or being told how to do it.
- Right. So it's, it's kinda, to me,
I need social skills.
Is that the correct word to say?
- Well, that's more job skills.
- Yeah, I would like to have that.
- The social skills are
helpful as well, of course.
- And be able to go places and feel happy.
Not, not be depressed all the time,
Or think about my problems,
because in every situation I
know there's complications,
some, some, some are worser than others,
Some are better than others.
So I kind, kinda. I just want
to be on the right track, man.
Cause if you are on the right track, Hey
you can go places.
Here It's like, we just a minimum,
Cause I don't know too much.
I don't know no one, I
tried to be to myself.
- Yeah.
I think that's the best way to be because,
being somewhere where you're not from,
if don't know something,
I try to ask someone and
hoping they give me the right,
Correct information.
Because without information you're stuck.
- Do you have, did you
graduate high school?
No, I didn't.
- You didn't.
So you're not really educated but,
but still there are jobs you can do.
You seem like an honest hardworking guy.
- Man I would love to be,
I don't care if just sweeping the floor.
get a job.
- Well, my channel has enough viewers now,
maybe somebody will see
this video and contact me
about getting a job for you,
and we can, we can set you up.
- Okay.
- Give you a shot
- All right.
That'll work.
- That'd be great.
And then, and then we'll,
I'll send you somewhere
down the street that
might help you work out,
Some of the stuff you want to talk about.
or you're welcome here as well.
Anytime.
- Okay.
- I think, I think with a little help
I can do better,
instead of coming
into something that you don't know about.
like it's hard for me to just
go to whoever and I don't
know what to say.
- Right.
- And when you don't know
what to say, you kinda,
you look stupid kind of.
- Yeah.
And I'm tired of looking stupid,
I need to be able to,
maintain my,
household.
Need to have a house.
- Yeah.
Right now I'm sleeping on the streets,
on the sidewalk,
and with tarps,
and crates and blankets.
Strange, But Hey, I don't
have anywhere to go.
- Do you, do you feel
like your social skills
are keeping you from having a job
or employment and just the
success that you're envisioning?
- Yes.
If I, I think I would've
paid more attention
in school, instead of getting
sent out all the time.
- Right.
I probably would have a good education.
- But you're able-bodied and
you're, you seem intelligent.
You seem able to communicate
with me just fine So.
- Yeah, but that's, I'm talking to someone
and I don't really know
that, that person so.
Being,
me dealing with relationships,
I'm not good at,
am not good at.
I got try to establish
what I'm supposed to do,
how I'm supposed to do it,
when I'm supposed to do it.
So I don't get confused.
And just trying to stay on the track,
is kind of hard sometimes.
- Yeah.
So,
I don't wanna
get somewhere
and it's a good job and I'm
not doing the correct thing.
So I want to be able to,
get somewhere in life.
- Yeah.
I know it's more, something
better than skid row.
- Yeah, Well I think just
a little communication
on your part and their part.
I think could solve whatever
issues there might be.
And with the right job, the right fit.
I think it could be,
it could be something that
you could help you get
off the street.
- Because this right here
it's hard for me to do,
but,
what Isn't hard?
Everything has that type of,
I guess how would you say?
structure, structure.
If I have more structure,
maybe I'll be able to
make it in life with it in life.
- Yeah. A little more responsibility
- Yeah.
- Than living on the street.
- I don't know the
correct words to say but,
this is a blessing.
That's all I can say to be able to talk
to someone,
that ain't on the other side judging me.
So it's, it's
it's a help.
I felt last time I was here, I left.
I felt I said man,
I kinda feel good.
Being able to talk about my problems.
It used to be hard for me to speak.
Now it's either to tell
a person what you mean,
what you say,
either be direct
and leave it at that.
- Yeah. you're a good communicator.
There's nothing wrong with your
communication skills, As I see it.
- I think it's little off,
I'm be honest with you.
- It just could be your confidence.
Your self confidence could be lacking
but I didn't detect any kind
of communication issues with you.
- Okay
- You're soft-spoken but
that's the only negative.
That's not even a negative.
It's just your, that's
your style of speaking.
- Yeah.
Not everybody's outgoing and loud and,
but you communicate very well.
- I noticed the way that,
I know you can't change the past
but you can, you can
predict your future as I,
as you would say,
- Build your future.
- Build your future or
I'm trying to get there,
on a slow man's pace.
So, if I can do it with
a little help, Hey man.
I think I can make it in life.
- Yeah.
Again you don't touch drugs,
you don't drink, you
don't do anything right.
- I don't do nothing.
- You just living on the street.
- Yeah, I have to.
If I, if I use drugs,
I'll be out of my mind,
and trying to survive
in a way, ain't no way
in help you should be able to do it,
down here and not stay focused.
Because you got everything down here,
from the robber to the
thief and the thief to the
to the man is just
walking across the street.
You know what I mean?
Getting away with wherever you can.
- Yeah.
I just want to try to better myself
because I know its was a better way,
And it just take time.
Rome wasn't built in one
day, I understand that.
When you're kinda
hyper about getting somewhere
or how would you say?
You want it bad enough.
- You're motivated and motivated.
- Yeah, motivated.
I just think you guys, man.
For not judging me, and
I don't know.
Lets see what we can do to help you out
- All right.
- Hard you.
Thank you very much.
- Okay.